we babies are having a crisis 100
well it's simpler if I just show you a
Kenny if you please but put on a show
but appear we go Jimbo hit the Lights
you see babies aren't getting as much
love as we used to great behold our
mortal enemy
Oh No that's exactly the problem this is
war
puppies are winning and babies are
losing all that news baby what are we
going to do you're going to help me
alright you still got it mom
yay now your parents will work for puppy
Co so have you learned anything from
them yes learning readjust let's go a b
c d no what have you learned about
puppies very puppy no Jimbo puppies are
evil Stacey be back for those I can't
read what could say this my team a
musclehead a bunch of yes men and a
doodler yeah what that cookie down
cookies stopper closer Hey Oh it's like
they're having a little meeting
[Music]
leaving the temple camp we're making
plans for their newest addition and your
new but this baby has a good plan
we babies are having a crisis babies
aren't getting as much love as we used
to behold our mortal enemy oh no that's
exactly the problem
have you learned anything hey me no what
have you learned about puppy good I'm
sorry No Jimbo puppies are evil Stacey
be back for those I can't read what
could say look Peary Oh like they're
having their own little meeting watch
desert humiliating you're going to write
the infamous John I know how important
this mission isn't the company duty
I got a deal the decay ID are you I'm on
a mission it's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why they'll
give me a double espresso and see if it
someplace around here would be some
sushi I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll
right about now
oh look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice if I don't succeed
with this mission I will live here
forever with you okay I will help you
but just to get rid of you deal you come
to me you know you're watching you too
okay shoot you on that how we can ask
the guard I've never been so humiliated
in my life better bring nothing I don't
we're not owe anything I'll have it done
to me what's all the racket I did he
adorable
oh I've got one for you too what bummer
we were the boss baby what that cookie
down cookies offer closer
you